bonjour tout le monde
aujourd'hui alors je vais passer dans le
vif du sujet mon sujet sera je me rend
heureuse
il ya quelques années je traversais une
période qui n'était pas facile dans le
cadre professionnel
je ne me sentais plus à l'aise je
n'aimais plus que je fais je me levais
le matin j'étais fatigué et c'était
vraiment une corvée d'aller au boulot et
il se fait que j'ai commencé à me
chercher à trouver des outils qui allait
me permettre de me connaître et de mieux
d'avoir vraiment arrivé avant et c'est
comme ça que mon parcours a commencé
dans les séminaires et séminaires de
développement personnel et y en a un
particulièrement tu m'a marqué c'était à
washington dc et je me suis retrouvé
dans une salle un peu comme celle ci et
j'étais assise à côté d'un couple couple
qui semblaient très amoureux l'un de
l'autre ils se regardaient mais vraiment
comme si il n'y avait que dans la salle
touché par la main et le conférencier
nous a fait faire un exercice où il
fallait énuméré les choses d'une rendez
heureux et là vous serez tous mais à
gratter à faire toute la vis de ce
pronostic me rende heureux et la jeune
dame assise à côté de moi tranquille
elle est restée sans rien n'est sûr
safer me suis dit merde et gonflé
celle-là vous a demandé de faire un
exercice et la voilà à 6 ménard à ne
rien mettre sur sa peine et c'est comme
ça qu'on appelle le tour de la table
arrivé à son tour le conférencier louis
dior vous de toutes les façons ça se
voit et ça se sent que votre mari pour
rendre heureuses je crois qu il n avait
rien et du bus elle s'est levée elle a
dit je peux avoir le micro ou bien
donner le micro il s'est levé
tranquillement gentiment elle a répondu
non non mon mari me rends pas heureuse
silence total dans la salle
d'abord hostile où le pauvre mari il va
ramasser mais vraiment et pas y aller
parce que voir carrément régler son
problème là et on va pouvoir le corriger
non a dit non nous ne le nions moi mon
mari ne me rends pas heureuse je me rend
heureuse je me rend heureuse waouh
ce jour là je crois que vraiment j'ai
compris ce qu'elle voulait dire par là
je me rend heureuse combien de fois ça
c'est vraiment le questionnement qui
pourrait qu'on est tous ensemble ici
combien de fois il qu'on ne pense pas
que le bonheur vient de l'extérieur faut
qu'ils aient des choses qui se passent
dans notre vie par exemple monsieur en
déclin est ce que vous pouvez passer à
notre prochaine style on se dit je
serais heureux si j'avais comme on a dit
tout à l'heure une grande maison au jeu
serait arrivé le jour j'aurai ma voiture
là on va pouvoir me respectent et dans
les îles ou alors je serais heureux
quand j'aurai rencontré mon âme soeur
et ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a
toujours la liste de l'âme soeur
recherche on le voudrait un peu comme
denzel washington où un peu comme
beyoncé avec des formes mais parfois ce
n'est absolument pas du tout ça qui nous
rend heureux
moi j'ai eu un très bon ami et ça je
veux je vais me permettre de parler
d'elle qui a tout ce qu'on pense qu'il
pourrait rendre quelqu'un heureux
hélas cette belle voiture là même des
voitures
hélas les maisons ils sont vraiment
comme on dit chez nous ils sont biens
fabriqués sont bien assis mais ce qui se
passe c'est que cet ami lorsque je me
retrouve avec elle elle me regarde comme
si elle attendait de moi une réponse
et quand j'ai essayé de comprendre ce
qu'elle voulait me dire j'ai senti
qu'elle était éteinte vide
elles ne sont pas utiles elle est
invisible aux yeux de son mari elle
n'est pas capable de dire ce qui ne la
rend pas heureuse et les vider sa vie
n'est pas heureuse
dans l atout mais elle n'a rien par
contre on a un vigile dans le quartier
monsieur kodjo mais ce monsieur vous le
voyez le matin des heureux il sourit à
tout le monde
il salue tout le monde il vous suit vous
demande comment s'est passé votre
journée pourtant il est vraiment très
heureux monsieur aux jo se révèle
maintenant on sent qu'il ya le bonheur
dans son coeur donc tout ça pour dire
que on peut croire que des choses
extérieures de rendre heureux
mais ce n'est absolument pas du tout ça
ce n'est absolument pas du tout
et le comble c'est que parfois on a
tendance à vouloir faire ce que les
autres voudraient que nous passions on
aimerait bien ressembler à ce que
l'autre voudrais que nous soyons via ce
manager par exemple qui est dans une
souffrance d'incroyable il a vendu un
mauvais profil de lui même à ses
employeurs il leur a fait croire qu'il
était bilingue vous avez un peu toute
cette liste de choses qu'on pense qui
pourrait intéresser l'autre l'employeur
et aujourd'hui il est coincé
il est coincé parce qu'ils n'arrivent
plus à sortir la vérité il est coincé
parce qu'il doit tous les jours
s'imaginer comment masser pour qu'on
attrape pas il doit fuir littéralement
de son bureau pour qu'on ne voie pas son
incompétence ne pas être dans sa vérité
ne pas être authentique ne pas être
nous-mêmes n'est qu'un mensonge qui nous
rattrape total et on est capable de se
rendre heureux on est capable d'être
aspiré à ce bonheur qui en nous il ya un
potentiel qui nous permet d'appuyer qui
nous permet d'être nous mêmes tout ça
pour dire que si on peut revenir juste à
la dernière faille une certaine ligne à
la 25 qui est une motivation speaker
aussi aux états unis elle a dit cette
phrase qui est tellement puissante
lorsque vous refusez lorsqu'on refuse de
paraître tels que nous sommes vous
emmener les gens à aimer ce que vous
n'êtes pas vous emmener les gens à aimer
ce que vous n'êtes pas donc c'est comme
si je vous donne une copie
un duplicata de qui je suis et pourtant
j'ai l'original et c'est cet original là
qu'on nous demande marcquois d'avoir qui
nous permettraient tellement d'être
soulagés est tellement d'être libérés
sur doux et d'être aligné dans notre
vérité alors la bonne nouvelle parce
qu'il ya toujours de bonnes nouvelles
dans mes histoires c'est qu'on a le
choix
on a le choix de faire des changements
on a entendu tout à l'heure mais si on
nous parlait du mouvement du corps
ce mouvement nous permettrait de pouvoir
un peu à y rester dans notre tête on a
le choix de bien manger par exemple
d'avoir des repas équilibrés
on a le choix de pouvoir être aspiré
avoir une vie spirituelle plus riches
on a le choix d'avoir une vie sociale
plus riches
on ne peut pas non plus avoir une vie
sociale ou disparaissez parce qu'on a
dit qu'il fallait avoir une vie sociale
non il faut rentrer mais on a le choix
de pouvoir équilibrer notre vie on a le
choix de faire des changements et c'est
des petits changements
et y'a que nous pouvons le faire y a que
nous personne d'autre ne pense à
personne d'autre ne me rase de
changement si nous ne décidons pas et là
passons lorsque vous commencez à changer
les choses wayne d'ailleurs dit ceci
changer la façon de voir les choses et
les choses commencent à changer
lorsqu'on commence à voir les choses
différemment ces choses-là qu'on regarde
commence à changer
d'accord et la société la plupart du
temps a tendance à nous pousser à être
qui on n'est pas à être qui on ne veut
pas être et ça ne vous amène encore une
fois notre quantité à cette façon de ne
pas être nous mêmes et on ne laisse pas
la perception des autres à notre sujet
devenir notre réalité
c'est ce que monsieur les bras à
l'américain qui est aussi un motivation
au speaker qui dit ne laisse pas la
perception des autres à ton sujet de
venir la réalité nous pouvons nous
rendre heureux
c'est vrai c'est possible commencer
quelque part et vous allez voir est
possible n'attendez pas une porte
extérieure une chose d'extérieur qui va
venir vous rendre heureux
vous continuez
alors lorsque nous avons atteint notre
sérénité lorsque nous avons réussi à
comprendre comment y arriver on a un
devoir vis-à-vis de l'autre on a un
devoir de pouvoir lui rappeler qu' il
est aussi important il est aussi capable
d'y arriver
vous savez dans chaque relation où dans
chaque situation
nous avons toujours la possibilité de
choisir comment on a envie d'être
lorsque les danses d'une relation par
exemple on peut soit disant y arriver en
étant supérieur à l'autre le dénigrer
lui montrer qu'il n'a rien d'important à
vous emporter ou à l'eau dans l'autre
sens on peut y aller en étant inférieur
et se dire toujours à eux en place dans
les grands jeux pas m'approcher c'est
pas la peine donc je suis inférieur il
ya d'ailleurs une histoire qui était
assez marquante aux états unis des
jeunes noirs de ghettos qui ont été
invités à la maison blanche chez obama
et ce jour là il ya eu du retard
le président a eu un tout petit peu de
retard donc ils sont arrivés dans la
salle et la salle était vide et on leur
a dit allez-y asseyez vous mettez vous
voulez est ce que vous savez que tous
les jeunes se sont mis sur les trois
quatre derniers rangs de derrière et
tout l'espace de devant était vide
son parti gars qui se dit maintenant
j'ai une opportunité de pouvoir
rencontrer ce président je pas lou
peilou de l opportunité il est venu se
mettre devant et quand il est venu leur
a dit mais pourquoi est ce que vous êtes
derrière la haie de la place devant il y
en a un qui a dit en fait non ça c'est
pas notre place assez pour les grands
c'est la place des grands et combien de
fonds se dit pas qu'on n'est pas capable
de pouvoir accéder à une place parce que
c'est toujours pour les autres
les autres peuvent mais il faut qu'on se
rappelle d'une chose non seulement
personne n'a le pouvoir sur vous
personne n'a le pouvoir et vous n'avez
aucun pouvoir sur personne du coup quand
on comprend là et qu'on le réalise
qu'est ce qui s'passe on se rend compte
que dans chaque relation il faut y aller
en étant d'égal à égal
tu as de la valeur tu as quelque chose
que je n'ai pas et j'ai de la valeur et
tu peux profiter de ce que je sais par
exemple je suis très bon en maths
très bon en langues toi tu étais très
bon en physique en sciences naturelles à
nous deux avec nos deux esprits on peut
arriver à faire des choses
extraordinaires dont je respecte son
intellect tu respectes qui je suis et du
coup on est dans une relation on
l'appellera gagnante gagnante
donc à chaque fois que vous êtes dans
une relation rappelez-vous tu as quelque
chose à mener et moi aussi j'ai qu'il
faisait à maisdon à nous deux on a une
force et du coup on peut se rendre
heureux et martyrise sa mère teresa a
dit ceci les paroles sont douces elles
sont courtes
enfin je le répète les paroles douces
sont courtes et simples à prononcer mais
leur écot et éternelle les parents qui
ont des enfants
montrez-leur ce qu'ils savent faire
parler leur donner l'heure cet esprit de
pouvoir se dire qu'ils sont utiles à la
société qui sont utiles à la vie et
steve a crié en s équipant d'office
commencé leur vie dans la société
en le couvant en se disant c'est cette
école là qu'on a envie de créer chez
l'autre de façon à ce que il ne parle
pas de nulle part
d'abord donc on est vraiment capable de
nous rendre heureux
on va tout doucement rentrer dans la fin
de cette présentation est une des choses
que je voulais vraiment vous dire c'est
que le moment présent
le moment présent est tellement
important le moment présent et si
important on a tendance à ne pas le voir
à ne pas le garder
lorsqu'on commence à réaliser ce qu'on a
là maintenant ici et maintenant c'est
énorme
on a réussi à venir ici on a pu marcher
il ya plein de gens qui peuvent pas
perdre ça ya plein de gens qui sont
coincés dans leur lieu à l'hôpital parce
qu'ils n'ont pas pu marcher
rien que cette notion de se dire qu'on a
quelque chose en plus par rapport aux
autres ça nous permet déjà de nous
recadrer de n'oublier complètement ce
qui ne va pas et le moment présent il ya
une histoire qui m'avait vraiment marqué
dans les journaux et j'avais vu ça
quelque part
un papa qu'on appelle en plein milieu de
la journée
on lui dise est-il votre fils vient de
faire un accident très grave
rendez vous
suite à l'hôpital pas paniquer ils
arrivent à l'hôpital
il trouve les infirmiers tout le monde
dans la panique qui voit son fils le
sang partout son coeur commence à battre
il demande mais où est le oui le oui le
docteur 1 le docteur arrivée on a appelé
mais je crois qu'il est sur le chemin
ils arrivent mais vite vite vite où je
vais perdre mon fils fait vite vite vite
un certain moment le chirurgien arrive
se dirige directement dans la salle
d'opération au pair le gamin près justin
vraiment de justesse il arrive à le
sauver il sort de la salle vient serrer
la main du papa en lui disant l'avait
échappé belle mais vous avez de la
chance parce qu'on a réussi à sauver
votre enfant le pape avait pilonné merci
mais vous n'êtes vraiment pas du tout
professionnelle
vous n'êtes pas du tout professionnelle
vous avez failli et nous permet d'avoir
une crise cardiaque
j'ai failli perdre mon fils moi et le
professeur leur égard avaient dit oui
vous avez failli perdre ou de fils mais
j'ai tout fait pour le sauver
parce que moi à ce moment là j'étais à
l'enterrement de mon fils que j'ai perdu
à trois jours tout ça pour dire que
parfois on a tendance à croire que nos
circonstances dont les pires où sont les
plus graves par rapport aux autres mais
rappelez-vous dans le moment présent
c'est le moment on peut se poser où on
peut être aligné avec nous mêmes on peut
vraiment mettre en place un système qui
va nous permettre de réaliser et de
regarder ce que nous avons hélas le
dalaï lama dit il n'y a que deux jours
dans une année où l'on ne peut rien
faire
les deux jours s'appelle hier et demain
pour le moment aujourd'hui est le jour
idéal pour aimer croit faire et
principalement vivre ne pas attendre ce
qui va nous arriver
mais après ce que nous avons aujourd'hui
et je voudrais terminer ceci pour vous
rappeler une chose de cher ami vous
pouvez vous rendre heureux
n'attendez pas une porte extérieure
n'attendez pas des choses qui n'existent
pas vous pouvez vous même arrivé à vous
rendre heureux
je vous souhaite une excellente après
viti mer